c'est la rentrée également dans
469 lycées publics d'Île-de-France
bonjour Valérie Pécresse bonjour hotma
bonjour donc vice-président de la région
de France et présidente bien sûr de
cette région
Île-de-France alors vous avez parlé ce
matin lors d'une conférence de presse
des nouveautés de la rentrée ici au
siège de la région à Saint-Ouen alors en
cette rentrée on parle encore de pouvoir
d'achat avec l'inflation qui est
galopante la région Île-de-France va
notamment maintenir le gel du tarif dans
les cantines pour plus de la moitié des
familles pourquoi c'était important pour
la région de maintenir ce gel vous savez
que depuis trois ans nous avons gelé
tous les tarifs de cantine pour
justement essayer de préserver le
pouvoir d'achat des familles face à
l'inflation alors on peut pas tenir
indéfiniment comme ça mais cette année
nous maintiendrons ce gel pour plus de
50% des familles c'est à dire que
jusqu'à un revenu de 4000 euros par
couple avec deux enfants et bien il y
aura le gel des tarifs il faut savoir
qu'un repas de cantine c'est un coup de
10 euros et que les prix aujourd'hui en
Île-de-France des tarifs c'est entre 50
centimes et 4,40 donc la région
subventionne près de 60 plus de 60% de
tous les repas des cantines alors il y a
aussi la fourniture pour les élèves qui
rentrent en seconde d'un ordinateur ça
c'est pas une nouveauté mais en tout cas
c'était nid ils vont avoir une mémoire
augmenter c'est bien ça absolument une
mémoire augmenter qui représente à peu
près un coup de 5 millions d'euros pour
la région parce que et bien on a de plus
en plus d'usages de cet ordinateur
plus la moitié des professeurs demande
très fréquemment aux élèves de la portée
et ces ordinateurs ils sont en tout cas
utilisés à 100% pour faire les devoirs à
la maison c'est un très gros outil
d'égalité de tous ces jeunes fassent à
au numérique et ça permet de mettre tous
les élèves vraiment dans une dans des
situations dans des conditions
identiques d'apprentissage ce qui était
très important pour moi parce que vous
le savez en Île-de-France nous avons 35%
d'élèves boursiers qui n'ont pas
forcément accès à un ordinateur
personnel à la maison et ça représente
avec les manuel numérique qui sont
embarqués un coup de 600 euros pour pour
un élève de seconde 270 en première 240
euros en terminale il y a une nouveauté
d'ailleurs en cette rentrée 2023 pour
accompagner les jeunes c'est le
lancement de l'application là-bas ce qui
sera disponible sur Google Play aussi
sur l'App Store alors la base
concrètement si une application qui va
recenser donc les aides et bon plan pour
les jeunes de la région les 15-25 ans
absolument les jeunes de 15-25 ans
trouveront sur la base toutes les aides
de la Région alors ça peut être des
aides transport on a une aide de 100
euros pour l'achat d'un vélo on a une
aide de 400 euros pour l'achat d'un vélo
électrique ça peut être aussi pour
pratiquer une activité culturelle ou
sportive ils auront un portefeuille de
100 euros qui pourront utiliser pour
soit s'inscrire dans une dans un club
sportif soit s'inscrire dans un
conservatoire par exemple et puis il y
aura tous les bons plans de la région
c'est à dire
la billetterie sociale des Jeux
Olympiques et para
4000 places pour la Coupe du monde de
rugby un certain nombre de places de
concerts que nous avons et que nous
mettons à leur disposition il y a aussi
l'accompagnement des jeunes notamment
dans la lutte contre le décrochage
scolaire alors vous avez parlé vous
votre mana cru ce matin du lancement
Dorian est-ce que vous pouvez nous en
dire un peu plus quel est le concept
comment ça comment ça marche oui on a
créé en Île-de-France avec la prison de
la région une agence dédiée à la
réussite à la promesse républicaine à
l'orientation qui s'appelle Oriane et
qui va aller chercher tous les jeunes
que nous n'arrivons pas à atteindre
aujourd'hui pour leur proposer des
formations la découverte des bons
métiers qui recrutent aujourd'hui en
Île-de-France et qui sont pas toujours
connus des jeunes on allant les chercher
là où ils sont sur les territoires on
aura un bus de l'orientation qui va
sillonner l’île-de-france à partir du
mois d'octobre mais aussi sur les
formats numériques aujourd'hui qui sont
utilisés par nos jeunes il y a cette
application la base dont tu as parlé à
la prison de la région mais il y aura
aussi la capacité à aller chercher ceux
qui sont en décrochage sur les réseaux
sociaux aller repérer à les mobiliser ça
sera aussi la capacité d'aller leur
proposer toutes les aides que nous avons
aujourd'hui mis en place avec par
exemple le permis de conduire que nous
prenons en charge en Île-de-France en en
finance 3000 désormais tous les mois et
puis toutes les formations aussi qui
sont proposées avec par exemple le
revenu jeune actif c'est-à-dire une
formation professionnelle qualifiante et
bien et un revenu pour pouvoir suivre
cette formation à condition d'aller au
bout faire un métier qui nous mène à la
réussite et c'est tout ce travail
d'insertion qui a été évolué par la
présidente on a tout remis à plat avec
un souci d'efficacité parce qu'on doit à
chacun de nos jeunes et bien de leur
proposer un chemin vers la réussite sur
tous les territoires en Île-de-France et
puis on s'est rentrée 2023 il y a bien
sûr la poursuite du plan d'urgence pour
les lycées on le rappelle 6,6 milliards
d'euros qui sont alloués à cet
investissement c'est le troisième poste
de dépenses en France c'est ça troisième
plan d'investissement derrière le Grand
Paris est derrière les Jeux olympiques
et paralympiques de Paris 2024 alors
avec plusieurs chantiers notamment des
chantiers d'envergure qui ont déjà été
livrés on peut parler peut-être du lycée
Jules Ferry à Versailles puisque ça
concerne les Yvelines qui est donc livré
un grand chantier de rénovation oui
un chantier de rénovation en Jules Ferry
qui était très attendu avec des ateliers
avec la demi-pension toujours très
compliqué de faire des travaux dans un
site historique avec à Versailles et
puis nous avons trois chantiers en cours
nous avons un chantier dans le lycée de
Carrières-sur-Seine dans le lycée de
Sartrouville grosse restructuration et
dans le lycée de Mantes-la-Ville donc
vous voyez 4 lycées
des Yvelines qui font l'objet de travaux
de grandes structuration après tous ceux
que nous avons déjà livré à
Saint-Germain-en-Laye le lycée
international de Bucq le lycée de
Saint-Germain et les lycées de lycée de
Poissy qui sont aussi en train d'être
rénovés l'objectif c'est 30000 nouvelles
places d'ici la fin de votre mandat il y
en a déjà 10 000 qui ont été livrés oui
on a 30
000 nouvelles places à créer alors
pourquoi parce que la région est une
région qui a une très forte dynamique
démographique nous sommes une région
parmi les plus jeunes de France mais
aussi parce que et bien les familles
quittent Paris elle quitte Paris pour
s'installer en petite couronne et en
grande couronne avec leurs enfants et
donc il faut qu'on adapte notre offre
scolaire à cette nouvelle donne
démographique et à l'attractivité des
départements notamment en grande
couronne c'est pour ça que cette année
nous ouvrons 1400 places seulement en
grande couronne et il y a un sujet
dernier sujet en cette rentrée bien sûr
celui de la laïcité avec notamment les
annonces du ministre de l'éducation
nationale Gabriel Attal on peut citer
l'interdiction la volonté du
gouvernement d'interdire la Baya dans
dans les établissements scolaires est-ce
que vous avez l'impression qu'il y ait
une nouvelle donne qui est donnée par le
gouvernement qui est-ce que vous pensez
de ces nouvelles annonces
d'abord ce que je veux dire c'est que la
loi de 2004 qui prohib tous les signes
ostentatoires religieux pour moi à
l'évidence interdit la Baya ou le
Camille dans les établissements
scolaires mais le problème c'est que sur
ce sujet là on a laissé les proviseurs
et les équiper pédagogiques seuls pour
faire appliquer cette loi de 2004 et
donc moi je me félicite que le ministre
de l'éducation nationale et enfin une
perle claire sur ce sujet parce que
j'alertais sur les difficultés
qu'avaient les proviseurs face à des
jeunes qui
venaient de plus en plus dans des tenues
qui n'étaient pas réglementaires donc il
s'agit juste de faire appliquer purement
simplement la loi de 2004 toute la loi
2014 alors cette application ne va pas
être facile parce que dans certains
établissements et on le sait aujourd'hui
des habitudes ont été prises voilà et
donc il va falloir faire preuve de
pédagogie de fermeté et il va surtout
falloir être aux côtés des équipes de
direction et les équipes pédagogiques
dans les lycées en tout cas la région
sera au côté de ses agents et si
quiconque sa visite de les menacer nous
nous leur donnerons la protection
fonctionnelle de la région un dernier
mot pour tous les deux pour les lycéens
justement qui font leur entrée qu'est-ce
que vous avez envie de leur dire que
nous faisons le maximum pour les
réussites et qu'on leur souhaite bonne
chance et une très belle année surtout
la région Île-de-France est la région de
tous les possibles et quand on est
lycéen en Île-de-France on a vraiment
toutes les chances de réussir des
équipes pédagogiques magnifiques et des
lycées qui se rénovent avec un plan
unique en France merci Valérie Pécresse
merci
Othman Nasro d'avoir été avec nous pour
cette première de rentrer du 7 8 très
belle soirée sur TV 78